[Musique]
et moi je pensais tu as vu ma fille tu
as vu le format il ya des gens calmes se
forme à tout le monde et par an à 4 bon
allez faut que je me mette une petite
boîte la bible au pardon non dit et j'ai
cru que ces terrains un petit sac de
sable aléas plus vraiment si je veux
vraiment du mal et guillaume rouch il
est à moi le gars ça mérite pas toute
seule et à coopérer dans frankie rouvert
depuis
je sens que tu as envie quelques tôt ce
pas sensuelle
n'abandonnez jamais
tu prends ça tu t'entraînes tranquille
je suis là je bouge pas enfin alors
nourri toi quand même parce que ça peut
prendre du temps cette histoire bona
pole dance attitude et n'oubliez pas que
soient plus facilement je parlais
d'enlever tombeau n'est pas te frotte à
une mort de trop peu la souplesse et des
la halle et la médiocre pendant deux
minutes j'ai vu la brèche et j'ai kiffé
comme ça tu es talent qu'on va trouver
une solution pour qu'il fasse un peu
moins car massa
[Musique]
s'cusez moi pardon jeu
marveaux